from the dawn of the Internet
young men have eaten the uneatable for
the benefit of their YouTube
subscription numbers
our next dining Daredevils are a rock
and hobo brown from Los Angeles can they
handle the hottest horseradish on earth
it's called nasal Lake partner this is a
pretty good name for this because this
is incredibly strong horseradish and it
is going to burn so why is this
horseradish too hard to handle
horseradish is a root it's related to
the mustard family and the chemical that
is creating this response is called
isothiocyanate now it's naturally
occurring in these plants because it's
supposed to be a deterrent for any
predators these chemicals are so toxic
they're toxic to the plant as well now
this means that the plant has a story in
a harmless form next to an enzyme that's
capable of breaking this form down where
the herbivore bites into the part it
breaks down the cell walls and these two
chemicals mix and this releases the
isothiocyanates the part is effectively
conducting a chemical attack on what
Evers trying to eat it yes it's a full
chemical assault and our intrepid
Daredevils but water should call the
burning right would chew as you can kind
of drink milk or something but there's
no way to stop these burning sensation
different say this I say tire cyanate is
a volatile get evaporates up into all
your sinuses and everything and it's
pretty difficult to get rid of because
it's a vapor there's nothing that can be
done but wait for it to vaporize and
eventually it'll just evaporate these
guys are my heroes I just had a little
bit of that and it just blew me over
don't try this at home